Hello everybody. Welcome to
This session on.
linear mathematics with python
now this session is actually the
first session of
a four-week course
titled linear mathematics with python
Now I will take you.
through the
curriculum
You know the topics that will cover and those
four weeks.
but in the
last third of the session
so first I will give you an introduction.
high level introduction as usual
to
You know what? We mean by a leader in mathematics.
We will talk about the applications of linear mathematics and
very importantly.
the prerequisites
as you know, it was as we have said before.
Mathematics is never something you could cover in a short span of
time.
Like in one hour and a half we could not become experts and
linear algebra, but what we can do.
but what we can do is
learn the fundamentals that we independently can learn.
Linear algebra or whatever bunch of mathematics. Let
me just answer this question. Where can I please find a
copy of the record? The recording will be a little available after today's Workshop?
If you join the slack Channel.
The link for which is in the Meetup page where you
always repeat you will find the link to slack when you go to slack you'll
find.
Updates there's also the big number Dash, but if you go to
the big number website.
And you enroll yourself in this course?
And all doesn't take much you just put in your email address click
on enroll and you have access to the material.
So either slack or the website itself?
Okay, let's talk about the topics very
quickly. So like I said quick overview of
linear algebra, like what are the
Main components that will be covered in this course.
Then of course the linear programming.
The prerequisites like what you should expect to
go through.
to we know
be able to read a literature on linear algebra
and apply.
techniques
from linear algebra and I'll give you a real good example one
of many examples that will cover in this.
in the course
now I haven't listed it
here but a big part of
Applying linear algebra in
the real world is with python in particular.
the library numpy
We'll talk about that as well.
But the numpy itself is reserved for
different session. Okay?
What is the linear algebra?
linear algebra
is actually a subset.
of
Abstract algebra, which I'm going
to be talking about today.
So even though this code is called linear algebra.
We really can't have a meaningful discussion.
If we are not.
speaking the same language or if we do not understand
each other because
In the context of linear algebra. We are going to
use certain words certain terms.
And unless we know those terms and you know.
We're not going to make a much progress. Now. Where
do we find the definitions for those terms?
abstract audio
so they are part of each other.
Okay linear algebra, like I said is a subset.
Of abstract algebra in other words if you
learn abstract algebra, you're on your weight. You're learning linear algebra.
Now in this course, there are two major components.
There are two things that we are going to try to cover in depth.
the first
category is the systems of linear equations.
one of the very
impressive things in linear algebra
Is that it gives us techniques?
For solving multiple equations at
the same time. It allows us to find the roots.
of multiple equations at the same time
why is that important well and
You know, what's the point of what's so in?
important about finding roots of an equation
I think I'll come back to that answer once.
We go to mark down because
I want to show you some math expressions.
Okay, but equations.
Which can sometimes stand for models?
And I hope you know that models.
Are how we mathematically represent some
thing in the real world?
By finding the roots of an equation.
And if that equation happens to be a model we would
have found the essence of that model.
And with linear algebra, we're able to do this for a seat
like a sequencer.
Equations, so that's the first one. Okay
again, I'm like we always do in every session we start at
the high level and then delve deeper right because we won't
have
a picture
of
the discussion
the second part is the Matrix operations.
This will be the bulk of the course and for
that matter this this encompasses the bulk of any here any linear
algebra course.
So I'll tell you what the subsets are like what
roughly goes into each category.
but let me also well actually this is it I this is
the slide I was gonna
I thought it was a slide that comes after but here are
the major components that we'll be covered in both
categories systems of linear equation. Like I said
allows you to or the set of techniques that allow us
to solve multiple equations at the same time.
and
we are going to we will achieve this.
by performing
arithmetic operations on multiple rows
And what we want to do is eventually get to something called reduced Echelon
form or reduced row Echelon form.
Another part of another topic.
Another thing that we will learn is Lu decomposition.
You know the lower triangle upper triangle decomposition.
and when it comes to Matrix operations we
have
a set of
special types of matrices
a very important one is a is the
square Matrix and that diagonal matrix.
These uh types of matrices especially this the
square Matrix is going to be very Central to the entire
course because Square matrices of applications in
neural networks.
In statistics if you've
heard of things like core variance and correlation matrices.
They have applications. Oh.
principal component analysis, which is
let's say our
What's the word I'm looking for?
It is where we are headed towards so well, and actually it's
the slide that I want to come to so principal component analysis. How many
of you have heard of PCA?
They whether you know what it like how to
evaluate or not. It's not the point. But how many you have heard of
PC or Episcopal component analysis if it's yes put in y if it's
a no type in a type of no just want to engage your familiarity with
some of these things.
Yeah, orange tries as Emma. Yes, because
it's especially data mining data mining where
we want to extract patterns and PC is what?
Is one mechanism one knee very powerful mechanism
that allows us to do that.
Okay.
And I've seen here we have people from everywhere.
including Saudi, Arabia Poland
Wow, Boston, welcome to you all.
Okay. So let's see the answers. We have many mostly wise
and a few ends.
now it's not easy for me to
Like going to PC at least not not just yet.
but
If we are able to find the principal components.
of a matrix
That's a big deal. We can do things like pattern recognition
whether it's from pictures or tabular
data or sound bites.
We it is used in stock price prediction.
So if any of your interested in quantitative Finance PC
is actually again a very big component
of
Quantity Finance optimization optimization
is is a subset of linear
or a superset of linear program which we
all talk about today. But PCA will give you a powerful
ability in many different
domains that concerns data.
now
in order for us to even be able to comprehend.
How PC works and how you're
able to extract the principle components from a matrix or
from our data?
We have this layer.
these layers of prerequisites
So for example PCA is a subset or a subtype
of sync singular value decomposition.
So in order for us to understand PC, we must understand how
what SVD is generally speaking.
and the prerequisite for understanding SVD
is knowing something called a characteristic polynomial.
The determinant function from which we can extract eigenvalues and
eigenvectors. I have a good sense. You most of
you heard of eigenvales and eigenvectors.
Okay.
And of course, we can only extract eigenvalues eigenvectors
or rather. We can apply determinate function to only
a square Matrix, which is one of the many matrices that we
will encounter, but perhaps the one we will focus mostly
on.
So if you want to pick up a book.
on machine learning
on linear algebra, or if you would come across a Blog and
you would to try to make sense. You know, what what is the formula
of PCA? You would get stuck at least I did.
And then I could figure out.
the prerequisites
and
this is this is what it looks like.
So the point I'm trying to make is in this course, we're going to learn linear algebra.
With the goal of eventually understanding
techniques like PCA.
Now we'll then open.
These opportunities for us.
You know to apply to diff all kinds to many kinds
of problems in the real world. Okay, so as
opposed to just learning these topics.
and abstract
and you know an abstract matter. We want
to see how every single concept applies to practical problems.
And we will do this with python. So you will Implement some of
these not or not. We cannot Implement all of these techniques
with
python
so for example, you can we can implement the terminal function
of python characteristic polynomial.
Is a little bit more.
challenging
but that's all we want to do so in this
Form you would not only learn linear algebra
an abstract algebra, by the way, you will also
become much better at Python and specifically not by.
Okay.
Let's carry on now. Let's talk about
linear programming
linear programming is very close to linear
algebra.
And it has this primary component called
The Objective function. It's just a
function
mmm, but
the point here is to either maximize the function or minimize
the function given some constraints.
So for example, let's say you want to transport.
Or let's use the shipping, you know like in
e-commerce.
and
there are some constraints that have to do with petrol consumption.
the distance traveled the weight of the
ships
the distance to
the recipients so you have these different constraints and
you want to
select the parameters.
Such that you're within what we call a feasible region.
I'll show you know, I'll show you an example actually example of this I'll show you both the mathematics
and the graphical.
Explanation because graphing is
actually a big part of linear programming especially graphing
any qualities, which brings me to the I'll
come back to this slide in a moment. But let
me just take a let me just jump ahead. I'll come back this basically. This
is a picture of inequalities, okay.
This is what it takes to this is
what you would have to encounter.
To be good at linear algebra.
Okay.
Like I said linear algebra is a subset of abstract algebra and abstract
algebra is a development or develops
takes the ideas from classical algebra
further.
also part of classical algebra
Is functions and graphing them.
In when it comes to vectors in
particular.
One technique that we will look at which has applications in.
computer vision and natural language processing by the
way a central
one of the things that we working towards
as neural networks.
So this is kind of it's also machine learning part of this course machine
understanding machine learning but no new electric specifically not
supervise and unsupervised learning.
We'll be working with vectors.
So we want to apply techniques like cosine similarity, which I
said has applications both in image recognition and NLP.
But prerequisite for understanding Vector operations
is trigonometry.
And trigonometry in turn has geometry as a
prerequisite.
what I'm trying to say is this
if you've ever enrolled in a course.
Or picked up a book called linear algebra. It is
assumed that you know all four of these at
least the extent.
That would allow you to.
read that book or
complete that course successfully
what I have done in this course is I have
made supplementary material for all four of these
So for example if we come across a word like a vector space.
The word space comes from abstract algebra, and if you
do not know what that is because you have to know what that is. If you want to make progress.
Well, then you can refer to this supplementary material.
Which talks about words like spaces?
And the axioms that apply to such a type
of set a space the type of set.
And of course in order to understand the axioms that apply to those
sets you need to know some classical algae, but nothing difficult is
very straightforward. In fact, we can cover
the key Concepts here today
and then there is trigonometry trigonometry is a big deal
again because of vectors, you know
must be
I mean, what are the applications of vectors whether it's computer
vision or even in even PC by the
way, you just vectors?
If we wanted we want to know how close they
are to each other.
So we need to understand angles.
The sign and cosine functions and for that we need to understand so basic
geometry or at least the notation geometry.
This again will be provided.
a supplementary material
Let me come up back up here. So let me this is an example of
New Year program. Let me give you a pictorial representation.
and then I will take you to
markdown
because through this exercise we will get a sense
of what systems of linear equations are which is from linear algebra
and
The objective function which is linear program, so, you know.
We learned two things with one example.
We have some.
function that we need to optimize to optimize means to
At least pictorially graph it so that
it satisfies all of our four constraints. So we
have these four constraints. So yeah and this function let's particular function
that we talked about has two variables. Okay. So
put differently. It's a function of two variables two things
two variables will affect.
It's maximization or minimization. Let's because
I know hypothetical example the price
of a smartphone.
It could be a function of the size of the screen.
and
How much memory it has rather mattress memory?
Or what's another example salary?
It could be a function of how many
years of experience you have.
And how many years you've spent in in school so academic?
Experience and work experience. Okay, so
that's salary will be of than we would
say that salaries a function and it's a function of two things.
Anyway here. We have a function. That is a
Whose valuables are X and Y both X and
Y Must Be 0.
So if you see here.
If we graph the inequality for X 0 x greater
than 0 then everything in the right quadrant.
And the first quadrant and the lower quadrant
would be highlighted.
Okay, so anything that is X anything that is equal
to or that's an inequality. I hope the pictures
are very clear, but that's an inequality and it includes zero.
It's a restricting equality. So anything from zero or above
X will be shaded.
then we have y
must be above 0 right so Y is this vertical axis
anything about anything from 0 or above will be highlighted?
But now we have two constraints if we take these two constraints together.
then
if we just focus on these two then how
do we satisfy both of these constraints? Well,
the Shaded area must be above
The origin for why?
and
To the right of X. So in other words we will have this region
that's
We basically slicing.
the Shaded area
But then there's more.
Here we have this other inequality.
2x plus 5 y less than
or equal to 3,500 which gives us this inequality. This it gives
us this graph.
So not only does our solution must be in the right quadrant in
the first quadrant.
We also have this, you know vertical this
diagonal line cutting through it.
So if we have this coordinate it was also sliced
it from here.
And then there's this fourth quadrant long story short.
we must
perform
arithmetic operations on these two these
constraints which they which are inequalities
and until we find the roots and once we find the roots of
these equations, we will then have found the feasible region
of
our objective function
Okay.
So let me show you an example. Let's let's switch to markdown talk
about.
Let's see a system of equation as in.
In practice and that we're matrices come
into the picture.
So I'm going to slide here.
to the right
Okay.
so
here is the example.
of systems of equations
now, let me make sure I have the correct example first.
Okay. Yeah, let's let's do this one first. Let's do the linear programming
example first. So here we have a linear example
linear program example.
Okay, you want to look here on the right?
Okay, I'm gonna type markdown markdown code.
But you look at the right, by the way, if you want to learn about markdown a
latex, which I'm going to be using you can also go to the
dashboard. There's a there's some reading material which you can check out.
linear program example
So let's say this is our objective function.
Okay, we want to.
Either maximize or minimize this
so we want to modify the parameters or
find out what X and Y must be equal to so that
this function will give us the maximum value or the minimum value depends
on the problem. If you try to reduce costs that you
would want to minimize the function.
If you want to for example increase Revenue, then obviously
would want to maximize a function.
One notation that you might see is for example.
The cute this would Max that's used before.
the functions name
So you may have seen this.
So this this is maximize the value and then there's something called ARG
Max.
Which means the arguments that maximize the function?
Okay.
So we want to maximize this function.
And these are the constraints that we have.
Okay.
We have this inequality.
We have these two inequalities in both X and Y Must Be.
Greater than or equal to 0 greater than equal to 0.
Yes.
Now the way we solve this.
The way we can the way we deal with.
These inequalities as we must solve them.
And what we're about to do is very similar to what we will do with systems of
linear equations and linear programming where we get to something called the
reduced Echelon form. I'll show you a picture of it in a moment.
So what we do first is we represent the inequalities
not as inequalities,
but as equations like so
so
These are the constraints.
as
equations
So these are inequalities.
These are equations. Okay. All we've done is
we've substituted the inequality with equal sign.
That's and let's label this equation. What an equation
two. Now, what we want to do again is find the roots of
both of these equations
So we want to know what x is equal to Y is equal and what Y is equal
to once we find what x and y equal to then we will find a point that we
could place in the quadrant and one
of the and irrelevant quadrant.
And by doing that we will have found a feasible region.
So what we will do.
Is we will subtract?
the second equation from the first
so we will subtract.
2X
from X Y from Y and 4,000 and
one 3000 so we will subtract these
together.
Okay.
And what does that give us?
It gives us x equals to 1,000. Why because well if you subtract y
from y y is eliminated 2x minus
X, that's just X and 4,000 minus three thousand. That's just
1000 again. This is classic eligible.
If you remember this is why you said they're pretty regular for linear
algebra is classical algebra. This
is just you know,
Adding on both sides subtracting both sides moving terms
to the other side of the equation.
Okay, so if you know these then
the linear programming and linear algebra are within your grasp.
Okay. So now we have found the first.
Root, we found the first variable X must be equal to 1000. Well,
now we can do is we can plug in X into
one of these inequalities. So what we will do is we will
plug in X into equation to
okay, so we will put 1,000 here for
x and then we will solve for y.
And we do that.
We will get the following.
Right. All you can see we've done is
We have plugged in 1004. Excuse me. We've applied
we'll plug the 1,000 for x.
Actually, yeah for here.
So here have X Plus y equals 3,000 now we have 1,000 plus
y equals 3,000.
Now that we just solve for y which gives us.
now what we have done is we found.
Y as well, so we have the points.
X and Y
and what are these points equal to?
X is 1000
and Y is 2,000.
Okay.
Now if I were to show you a picture of this.
Feasible region it will look.
Like so let me actually put the picture
on Google Drive. So give me a second to pull it up.
Okay. So by the way, this is how we will how
we will do the class. I will use markdown.
I'll use marked out and during these session. We will
also do we will Implement these in Python?
So let me download the picture because it is actually rotated in
the wrong direction. Let's download this thing.
I can show you the plot.
And let's rotate it.
There we go. There are the points. So that
is our first constraint that is our second constraint. We
use we perform arithmetic
operation on both of them. We see in this case. All we did
was subtract now practice.
You're you're gonna you're gonna have more than two constraints and
you're going to do a lot more.
row operations
something in linearity. I'll cut this in moment. But as you can see once we have
found the point once we have found the roots, we now
have or are able to plot the feasible region.
So as long as the parameters.
Are within this feasible region then our objective function is
optimized.
And again optimization means that the function will give us maximum.
Results or minimum results depending on what we're trying to do.
This is essentially what linear programming is.
Okay. Now obviously this is a very simple example, there's more something that
we've also cover in this code is called a Simplex algorithm.
And if you learn linear
program within you can even attach something called nonlinear programming
where you're constraints are not linear,
so they are polynomials.
Okay.
There's a that was a simple example now.
Let's see how this relates to linear algebra. Let me open another tab
here. This is an example in linear
algebra.
So if we take a
sequence of equations that are set of equations like so
again, you want to look here right in this panel.
maybe activated
here again we have
A set of linear equations I can
how do we know it's linear all of the variables or I
should say. None of the variables are
to the power of two or above everything is to the power of one.
That's why it's called linear produces a line if there was a square or
if it was square or cube, then we would
we looking at curves.
What we do a linear algebra is we take all
of these terms both from the left and rights of
the equation.
and who isolate the constants like so
so we take two.
And one and one from XYZ respectively,
so that's what we get here.
and then of course the fourth column
is a
the value of the rights of the equation
the way we would solve this equation first
of all to solve it means to
Your solution I don't I don't have time to
do the solution but essentially you must have
I have to show I have to show a picture but what we
do is we have the essentially find the roots. We have to find out what x is equal to
what Y is equal to what Z is equal to.
By eliminating these constants like we
did in the linear program example.
Okay, so let me show you a picture on Google
because I didn't have one ready here.
I'm gonna type in reduced row Echelon form.
It will look something like that's fine I could
picture.
Let's see. This is a good one.
This is an example. So this is applications both in.
linear programming
And by extension, it has applications and
economics in finance and transportation
or Logistics.
And so look at what we've done here again, we've we're using row operations.
So we for example add one equation to
the other equation or we multiply one equation to
another equation or a multiply one equation with some
number and then add it to another equation.
If you do this by hand, it is very cumbersome.
Okay, the linear example, I still linear
program example actually was very trivial it was we only had two
examples here. We have three and even in this case you have to do a
lot of addition subtraction multiplication to eventually find the
route. So here are the roots X is equal to 2 Y is equal to negative 1
is equal to 3 and it's called the reduced row Echelon
form because look here.
all what happens is that in order
to know that you've actually found the solution
or the roots for all three equations
or the roots for all of these variables is you get
this form you get this diagonal form you
can you see how we have why excuse me one across
the principle diagonal
When your Matrix looks like this, let me
zoom in.
When your Matrix looks like this or you have one in
the first row and zero zero then one in
the second row in the middle.
This diagonal basically, once your Matrix looks like that you can
then substitute the values back into your equation. So for
example X Phase 1 to become zero
three becomes zero.
And now it becomes two. This is how you
would what have found the roots of your
a roots of these of all three equations
And again I said this is important. Why because let's say
you have multiple models.
again Financial modeling, for example
If we said that a model is supposed to be representation not
necessarily technical precise representation,
but representation on the less.
So models which have come the form of equations
most of the time if you were to find the roots
of those equations, then you would have understood why
this model behaves a certain way.
Okay.
The the the model the equation
for force is one example Force equals mass times acceleration,
okay.
So if you're able to find the roots, then you can get to the essence of
the model and then you can use that to for regression
and machine learning.
okay, so the real world you actually have
You have to handle multiple models at the
same time and linear algebra gives us techniques for
that. Now I said earlier that this is very
cumbersome to like you have to do a lot of manual arithmetic which brings
us to python.
with python we can't solve systems
of
linear equations like this
almost instantaneously
so we don't have to do this by hand, but
we still want to have the capability to do it.
So what we will do is we can we can do linear programming.
in
you know a large.
sets of equations on large sets of constraints
with a library like numpy.
Okay. Anyway, this was supposed to give you a glimpse into.
the first part of
the first let's say have of linear algebra, which
I said.
Is systems of linear equations, then there are the Matrix operations
that we're going to look at.
For this we have to talk a little bit about abstract algebra,
which you will in a second.
But we also need to know the different types of Matrix. So these are
the types of matrices that we're going to look at one type
in types of matrices.
Types, here we go types of Matrix.
And these are some of the types of matrices.
now if you are going to learn machine learning
and this is not all of the types of matrices, but there are matrices
in the
for complex numbers as well. But anyway if you
want to
If how many of you by the way attended the ml papers
session?
last week
if you were here for the ml papers episode 1 please type in why
I just want I just want to check something happen one. Otherwise type in
n
Okay, okay a few people were here anyway
in that in that episode. I was
going through one particular.
paper one influential paper or machine learning
and
for that example, if you go watch the video or if you read that paper and
for other examples that we're going to look at in the second episode.
We're going to use.
terms
and when you hear those terms like if I say a diagonal
matrix, you must be able to visualize it.
Okay, and this is true for
Any any literature on
neural networks, as you know, neural networks
are perhaps the most.
Let's say versatile.
Form of machine learning because we can use new networks for regression for
classification for clustering. What have
you
And really to truly understand
how deep learning works and then implement.
Those new networks in something like tensorflow or
Pi torch. You must know the types of matrices. We
have a linear algebra.
And why you would use one of the other so for example the unit Matrix
or something called the identity Matrix
these Matrix allow you to change just swap the
order of the values in The Matrix.
Let me show you an example. Let me show you let me come back to the starting to
tell you why you would want to know the different types of matrices.
Okay.
So if you remember maybe you don't know. But anyway, this is an this is
a slide. I borrowed from ml episode elbow papers
episode 1.
so
let's say we have this picture.
It's very blurry picture.
and
we want to train a machine learning model a deep
learning model.
to
predict what's in this picture the classify the
object in it?
well
Machines, do not understand what pictures are machines only understand numerical
quantities. Now we can
do that because right now we're looking at a black and
white.
Picture so it's one channel.
and
in one in this black and white Channel what we have
are pixels.
These pixels are associated with numbers. What are those
numbers the range from 0 to 255?
where 0 is a perfectly black pixel
and 255 is a perfectly white pixel.
Now you probably can't see the numbers on this.
here, but
you should see that this is the number 10 number 11 number six be there
very dark pixels and here on the
forehead. You know, we have numbers that are 200 above
237 Etc.
Okay, and if we just look at the numbers alone once again,
you can see we have a matrix of numbers.
Oh what these numbers represent or the intensities of the pictures? Okay.
now
in order for us to
find the weights.
of
the features of a picture
we need to use different filters filters are matrices that
emphasize different.
patterns in the picture
Let me show you an example.
If you see here we have the picture
of the number four.
Okay, so it's a picture that has
it's either black or white.
So they're no Shades of Gray. So here the pixel 0
represent black at the pixels one represent quite
pixels, by the way, what we would do when before we
are ever do machine.
Learning for image is we normalize the pixels to normalize
the musical from 0 to 1.
So here one is a white pixel.
now in order for us to to you know for the
mission to see so to speak what we
to see the features of this picture
we have to we have different angles to look at we have
the vertical lines. We have the horizontal lines. We have the diagonal lines.
So here we see it says here apply filter. The filter is
the Matrix.
in this Matrix
We will.
Put once in certain cells and zeros and
other cells to highlight or to extract
different parts of the picture.
So for example here.
I can show you a
the different types of combinations. There's a very nice
web page that
allows you to in real time. See what different
kernels do to a matrix that represents the
picture.
But there is one filter that we will apply that will extract the contents
of the vertical line. So it will go it will only look at the vertical lines
of the picture.
As you can see here.
This filter was able to extract.
the left vertical line of the number four
and the right vertical line of the number four
But then we have another filter which is again a
matrix that will highlight the mid section of The Matrix.
So you can see was able to spot the vertical line.
So the horizontal line security so we have the vertical lines now.
and the horizontal line
and that diagonal allowed the diagonal is not
really special in this Matrix. So
the signals are not as strong.
But what we that's the idea here, we will we have
can have different filters. It doesn't have to be three can be 20 30
60 or whatever and we can use different filters to
extract different.
features from the picture
hopefully you kind of appreciated necessity of
Matrices, let me actually take you to the blog.
Hopefully I can pull up pull up the picture. But in the
meantime look at this and I'll while I pull up that what I
put up that blog.
so picture
now by the way when you look up
Some sort of article or video on new networks. This is the kind of diagram you
would see.
Or here's another one. This is for
Image this is for image recognition.
So you go from Matrix or
a tensor of matrices
to eventually a vector
Okay. So again in order for you to really understand how a
new Networks net new little works. You must first understand the
types of matrices. What are the use cases? And then
how you would apply arithmetic operations on those matrices? Here's
another one.
This is for a secret information. So if you do if
you're interested in Time series for finance.
or
any any sequential type of data for let's say
voice to speech or speech to text
Again, you would see diagrams like these but these are actually nothing more
than Matrix operations. So here's an equation. For example.
See if you can make out what these characters are by the way
mathematically speaking. This is a neural network.
It's expressed with these terms.
You'll have a look at that try to figure out what this equation is trying
to do.
Or what I try to communicate. Well, I while I pull up the block for you,
so
Let me open up my slides.
kernel
image
block
If I don't find it, we'll just move to abstract also, because we want to talk about
that.
Oh, look at that lucky day. I was able to
find here. Let's look at this.
So here this is an actual picture.
And so what you see here on the right?
If I move my mouse, that's the actual picture.
Yeah.
And this is the Matrix representation. So
the intensity of the white pixel.
If I pick somewhere here on the chin.
You could see a number closer to 255. I
hope you can see it's just two one six.
There we go.
Okay, and where we have a black pixel we get
numbers that approach 0?
so which is like
the Shadow on his neck.
now
this is what a kernel is.
a kernel or also synonymously used
the word filters also used to we will
use kernel and filter interchangeably both of them are matrices. So if
you see here
On in this Matrix. This is a sharpening kernel.
So if you want to for example sharpen the picture.
you can set up the curl like so we have
That I have to be careful with my mouse.
So you can see we have zero negative 1 0.
And then 0 negative 1 0 and then five in
the middle.
And what we do what this kind of will do is do you
see this red grid?
That is that filter it is going to apply.
But we're going to basically multiply the numbers in
the kernel with segments or
we say super pixel of the picture and we
go stride by stride. Again. This is a term you
wake up across a new networks we go stride by
stride applying this kernel basically multiplying the
numbers again like from Once there
are pixel to the next Super pixel.
And then by the time we're done by the time we get to the bottom
of this.
Matrix multiplying multiplying multiplying multiply
multiply
we would have done produced this picture.
Now that the picture is sharpened.
It is very clear where the eyes are where the
nose and what the outline of the faces.
This makes it easier. If you try to do something about Optical record
Optical calculator and the pictures are
blurry or there's a lot of or there's not enough contrast.
Or if you're trying to do facial recognition, you can pre-process the
picture.
but if you want to know how to preprocess the
picture and there's a I don't know a book on machine learning that
gives you the formula, but you cannot and if you're
not able to read the formula if you're not able to understand what
Linear algebra technique you're applying then we will not be able
to put implement this in a python.
Here's an experience that I've had and I'm sure others have
as well.
you
You find a notebook a Jupiter Notebook
on tensorflow or pytorch.
And you want to adjust it for your problem. You want to adjust it for
your own data?
You may not know I'm assuming okay. Let's say not every now some
of you may notice but most people do not know what a convolution
layer is.
Do not know. What our kernel Matrix is or what our filter
Matrix is do not know. What kind of evolution is to begin
with a convolution is a special type of Matrix operation.
So if you do not know what a convolution is this type of operation.
That you apply to two matrices of different dimensions.
What we're gonna end up doing you're gonna end up playing around with a
goal going back and forth running the notebook from scratch. Hoping
to see a different result. That's not going to get you anywhere.
But if you understand the mathematics.
what a convolution is like in actually like
the mathematical operation convolution is the different
types of matrices. Well, then when any time you come across
a paper like an archive?
You can Implement a python.
And that's really what we want to do. We want to learn to do in this
in this course.
how to go from math
to python
to solve a real world problem
and we will look at examples like I said in economics and
finance and neural networks.
So hopefully understood one.
Reason why you want to look at? Why do you want to understand? Learn
the types of matrices then? Of course you have different types of
You know.
types of matrices for example we have the blur
you can see the numbers are closer to each other.
So if you want to Watermark something or blur something,
let's say in a video.
Then you would you'd have to look at the way you
would set up the kernel Matrix.
Okay, so that's another example.
Okay.
How many of you recognized?
the
the symbols at least in the first equation
like you have a sense of what this equation is.
involves
If you kind of understand what the equation is doing.
I'll give you a hint. By the way, the the five function
here is the activation function and your network.
If you know what this equation is, just the first one type in
y. Otherwise type in in the chat.
Ron says yes Allison says, yes, Rich.
Eleanor says yes.
I'm gonna guess we have a 50/50 split.
Yeah, so more or less. It's more or less
50/50.
so
the vertical bar above H. That's
just the mean average.
The activation function is
well, I can stand for different types of
either linear or nonlinear functions.
I don't have a picture to show you but the W is
definitely a matrix.
and it's super script t means
the transpose of the Matrix so Russia's hypothesis
sub 1
what do you mean by hypothesis?
No, actually the H stands for hidden layer.
So hit the first hidden layer.
Is given by The Matrix of the the
transpose of the Matrix one?
multiplied by
the scalar value X which is the mean average. Anyway, the point
of trying to make is that we want to enroll in
this course and completely expose ourself to
mathematics.
Explore is the meaning of Acts exactly, but that's from statistics.
Okay.
now
let's let me show you a few things that you might encounter and
then how you can go about making sense of them. So this is
what I try to expose it some abstract algebra.
Gilbert Strang anyone would have Gilbert's trying Gilbert Strang
is Professor MIT who has authored several
very
Influential books both are linear
algebra and application of lineage. So one of the
books that he's written. It's called the linear algebra.
And deep learning or something that I affect.
And learning from data is the one.
This book is excellent.
if you want
to become better at Deep learning
The challenge is this linearity Pro book assumes.
professions in the new algebra
Eleanor says I have this book in a highly recommended. So do I
I would recommend any book by Gilbert strength.
He also has YouTube videos
on.
Yeah, he has videos on YouTube from MIT open coursework.
And he has this to say he says he there's
one video. I think it's about 15 minutes
long and he says he talks about
the big picture of linear algebra so quickly Google
it here.
Or I think I had these slides from before.
The Page open from before it's this
one.
Yeah, here we go.
So he sets up.
The foundation of linear algebra and it takes it from there.
So if I scroll up he talks about
the four fundamental subspaces
of linear algebra
and
he has he describes these four
subspaces the row space the null space.
and the column space
now the word space.
Phi is an activation function, I'll come
I'll open a picture in the Google and the tab and I'll
talk about this in a moment.
I mean, but if you're not familiar with neural networks.
You might have to cover some.
Background, but anyway, if that's something that interests you can take the
course. I'll talk about the curriculum in a second.
Here they would space.
in mathematics refers to set
A set is a space a special
type of set to which certain rules apply.
So for example if I scroll down let me
show you an example.
There were okay. So there are actually two things that I
want to highlight two things that will cover. One of them is a notation.
to which you want to be very or you want
to have
you want to be?
You want to pay particular attention to like you need to be
able to spot a vector?
Unity of differentiated Vector from a variable or a
matrix from a random variable.
And I'll show you what I mean.
But let me see if there are other references abstract algebra. So
then I have a reason to take you and talk about abstract algebra.
Let's say maybe is there a vector space in here
that I see before Vector space?
Because if I turn this into a if I
start from scratch, it's gonna bore you.
There you see we have references to trigonometry.
Okay, so let's talk about let's talk about let me show let
me introduce some notation.
Let's talk and then let's do this exercise right
or I will show you the the alphabet of linear
algebra.
And then I will bring you back to this document and hopefully you
might be able to get a better sense of what this is talking about. So,
let me come over here. Let's open a yeah, let me let's add here.
So this is
this says we said we call this systems if equations
systems of
linear equations
but now let's talk about
the syntax
Now what is a matrix a matrix is a tabular structure
like the one we looked at earlier?
Okay.
Let me just add a few line breaks here again. You just look at the
right panel.
Don't get distracted by.
What's going on behind the curtains now a
matrix?
Is primarily represented with an uppercase letter
and you want to follow that convention?
so for example m
The capital letter M is used to denote
matrices.
But not just capitalization. It also has to be bold.
like so
Now what if you cannot?
The problem is you cannot make matrices, you
know when you're doing this by hand you cannot.
Make the font a bold. Okay. So all
the alternatively matrices can also
be represented with two underlines. This is not something
you will see a lot but nonetheless.
It is it is used so it is
indicated by two.
underlines
They're right.
like that
So you need to be?
careful about this if you see either one of these notations
They're both referring to matrices.
Okay, so if you cannot make it bold, you would draw two lines.
Then there's a vector a vector is either one
column or one row.
And vectors are denoted in two ways as well.
Either with the Bold but lowercase letter.
like so
So we'll be a sequence of values like two one.
one and twelve
Okay, but again, you cannot
make it bold and writing. So more popular convention
is to put an arrow over
the letter v.
like so
both of these refer to fees so when you're reading to
the text, you must know when you're looking at a
Valuable a regular variable or a vector row
Matrix then there's a transpose.
This is the transport the transpose means to turn the row to a
column.
Or the column to a row.
So if you would take V.
and put superscript t
What we're doing is we are turning this thing.
Okay.
If you put a t over V, then this will go
from being a row to being a column.
So we get something that looks like this.
Just gonna copy this later code.
and
what do we have? We have two one.
two one
one and 12. That's what
a transpose is. That's it.
And of course if you apply transpose again, you'll go
right back to what you had before.
The same is true for Matrix. I'm not going to do the code now. But
if you if we were to transpose this then two one
one twelve will be on the first column.
Six five negative three six would be on the second column and you
get the idea. That's what a transposes.
Let's come back here to look at other notation. So now
you can hopefully see what's going on in.
Gilbert strangs writing he doesn't either make it bold
or put to underlines so you have to know from
context.
What these letters represent?
Then we have two vertical bars. What is
it? What are these two vertical bars?
So we have two vertical bars.
And let's put in UV.
What does this represent anybody know?
Ron asks, our vectors assumed to be columns. No.
You have to read the the writing to
see one of the referring to so up here.
Let me see if I can show you an example.
They will say for example column vector or
row Vector. You have to like read obviously cannot you
cannot always like infer from the equation alone.
You must also read the read the writing.
Here, for example, I said eigenovactive X. So again, I would
I this is not
the best
Way to represent the vector like you just have to
put our on top of order make it bold. But anyway here says
it is the First Column so you would have to read.
So you from the context you would know if it's a column or a row?
Exactly them. That's the magnitude of the vector.
The magnitude of the vector is the size of it.
Okay.
Okay now let me talk about something else.
Now, of course, we will go into more depth like we will go
into Matrix operations. We will talk about
solving
and Performing operations on matrices of different dimensions,
but
in different in different session
So again, hi. We want to start the high level and then gradually will
make our way.
to
born in the topics. So here
Those vertical bars which sometimes
are represented with.
single vertical bars
indicate this so we have v as a vector.
And to know the magnitude of the vector.
is to take
the I think this is that this is a vector of
points.
But anyway, what we do is we take the component squared.
and the square root
and this is why we do you can calculate distance
of a point on you play in.
or a Cartesian
coordinate
Okay.
So again, the emphasis here is not to solve.
Problems one by one. I mean that is part of it, but it is actually
to put emphasis on the
the syntax. So for example, you
would know that this is perpendicularity.
Well notation that is used both in Geometry trigonometry
and here in linear algebra.
Okay.
Okay, so let me come back here.
And talk about what will be covered in the course.
So here's a dashboard.
in the first week
We're going to talk about linear algebra.
From historical perspective when I say historical perspective. I
don't mean a history lesson. I really actually mean
going into abstract algebra.
because
remember we said that we whenever you're learning mathematics, they're always
two problems that you have to talk of all of the syntax.
The other was a terminology now much of the terminology and
linear algebra comes from abstract algebra.
So we will have to kind of take a detour
to switch the abstract algebra to know what spaces are
what sets are what axioms are
so that we can
continue
You know or make better progress on.
learning linear algebra
Okay. So this first module will emphasize let me actually take
you to the lesson plan. So we see things in more detail.
Okay.
So this is the first session we've kind of had an overview of both linear algebra
leader programming this the second session will be
about
we will briefly talk about waste for solving system
of equations one example with math, but also
with python because I said because if you
want to solve some equations by hand, it's really cumbersome. It's not enjoyable.
We want to talk briefly talk about graphing equation inequalities, and
we want to do this in Python. So
You know the library matplotlib.
We will use math plot lip. So we will have a numpy
so we can represent multi-dimensional data
and then we would use mathplotlip to plot graphs.
Both the equations any
inequalities. So again if you need
to go deeper into python
if you're interested in machine learning and you want to know how
if you want to become better python for their purpose of machine
learning this would be
You know a good course to take.
So graphing equations and inequalities. And like I
said, we have to go inside abstract algebra to cover
some background and then that way we can
make
a better progress with our study
in the second and third modules
We're going to go deeper into Matrix operations.
So yes, we will cover linear program. So we'll talk about the Simplex
algorithm and we will look at practically examples
in economics and
finance. So but this will all be in Python. Okay, there will
be the mathematical.
Expressions you would have to implement in Python.
We will talk about yes, the different types of matrices. You
will learn about Square matrices diagonal matrices
inverse matrices.
The ones we just looked at.
Now why is this one two
or three weeks long? Well because we need to spend time to learn
about we want to this two weeks also.
Leads up to understanding PCA.
And if you remember the slides I said we have to cover substantial ground before
we can really get comfortable with PCA.
So if I take you back module two
and three is going to emphasize on these parts.
Okay.
Again, we will learn the mathematics of these so
you will know how to go from a square Matrix to PCA.
But you'll also know how to find a principal components with
python.
With numpy you'd actually be able to do that.
Okay, so it's not pure Theory it's theory and
practice. So two weeks spent for
this.
Module two or three will be this and of
course applications of PCA.
So you will have an example for machine learning.
feature engineering not machine feature engineering
what example or in finance and
another example in logistics?
Okay, then.
We will turn our attention in module for
the fourth week to machine learning now. Like I
said, it's not going to be about supervised and unsupervised learning but deep learning specifically.
So we will talk about neural network those that literally
equation. I showed you earlier will know what that equation is. So we
will know what activation functions are. We'll know what weights are.
We will know what a convolution of a matrix is we will know what
filters and kernels are and this will be implemented with tensorflow.
So the examples if we talk about we see
a mathematic representation, but then apply them in
tension flow.
Okay, so if you want to be good attention flow again, this will be
an ideal course for you. And then we will look at examples of those neural
networks. We will use new networks for
forecasting
regression so I I did say we want to supervised learning
what I mean is we won't look at stuff like linear regression
and random photos random Forest
regressor.
But we will look use new networks for forecasting numbers
for image recognition and one example
would set them analysis. So image recognition
falls under the category of computer vision center analysis comes
under the category of NLP.
Okay, and there's all some text people. There's some
text preprocessing involved because if you
want to do Center analysis, we have to convert words.
to
Numbers if you remember from our last session ml papers
when we talked about wood vectors, so we will do
that as well in.
and in practice
But that will be like a couple of days. Okay, so
we cannot cover a new networks or the Practical applications
of new networks in one session. Each session
is one and a half so we'll be a few days.
Okay, and by the end of this course you
would have completed a project.
You would have completed project for neural networks.
for all three examples
and you would have have one other notebook
for PCA.
Now in this course, by the way.
if you want to get
If you want to get a certificate if you want, the certificate
we have to collect everyone's assignments and
exercises we have to and that's submit it for
certification. So if you want the certifications, you
have to complete the assignments for all four modules.
And then you would be eligible for the certificate. Okay,
there will be you will there will
be grades and you will get feedback. So the way we do
it by the way, if you want to preview if you want to see how one of
the courses are conducted go to the main page of big number.
mathematics and programming finished
a few weeks ago
so you can just click here. Learn more go to the course.
and then you can see
You know the types of exercises we do.
the types of assignments you're given and by
the way if you need a
If you want a introduction to python like you're new to
python or you want to refresher this course has that so
there's a complete tutorial on python.
And of course it goes into set theory, so this would be great.
So, however, if you want you can look at this.
But if this course interests you go ahead and
sign up.
Just go to the website.
click on linear mathematics
sign up with your email and you're through now, obviously the video
will be available.
by tomorrow
and I will have some writing materials a
PDFs attached for these documents.
And also here's what we do where we
have our discussion. So right now this is the
mathematics programming Channel which we finished.
Two weeks ago. So what I do is I give exercises during
the class and there will be assignments outside outside the
class.
So join the join this channel.
Go to Slack.
Join, the linear mathematics for python Channel if you've already signed
up.
I noticed like 10 people have signed up on for
this course. What I will do is I will manually add you to
the big number slack Channel.
But if you haven't done either of those I suggest you
sign up now and in you know, just join this
channel.
Because the next session will be on Wednesday.
the second episode
Okay.
Now any questions from anybody about what we covered today or any
questions in general?
Is there anything you would have wished to have learned from this
session that we I did not talk about.
Any questions about the course? Yes. Go ahead, please.
Yes, so when is the right time to ask
queries and would be the session or at the end
of the session?
So what is the protocol?
You mean in the course?
In this course here.
You ask you can
either turn on your mic or you can put the question the chat.
So this session is was actually introduction.
And no no my audible mitel
your little time. Not sure. Yeah, I
can hear you. Can you hear me?
He says I can hear you some query is that when is
the right time to ask the questions in between
your presentation is? Okay that if something is
not clear then can I unmute and
ask queries or should I wait till the end,
you know? Okay, you can you can it's a workshop.
So these sessions are Workshop so it's but by
the way the way it works is I'm gonna cover some concept then I'm
gonna get I'm gonna give exercises. So the way I do it
Let me show you an example from the other course.
here for example
I post an exercise. These are the exercises file.
And their support you you're supposed to solve so you will be given anywhere between
10 to 20 minutes to solve the exercise and then you have
to spend your attachment to me. So at any point of it's
not clear you can ask a question turn out the microphone or put in
the chat a second like imagine a physical classroom,
right? How would you go about interacting it would be
just like that.
Alright, perfect.
Yeah, that's very good.
Perfect. Great any other questions?
about linear algebra linear programming courses
Hey, Danny.
Hi there, Ron.
Yeah, I had a question about that. Graphic you
pull down from Google.
Of the Matrix is that it
had a vertical bar in it?
Really?
Yeah, let's see. It was a
three by four Matrix. You just grabbed it
from Google.
this one
mmm
similar to that, but it was
Okay, let me see it. It was like
a four by three Matrix and there was a vertical bar going
down the right side of it.
Well, I think that was Gilbert strikes document. Let's
see. I could have been that. Yeah history.
recently closed
I think that's the one.
this one
that's seeing it in there.
I thought it was an image that you said you just gonna grab it from
Google.
but
it wasn't in the slides. No, that's cheated. So no, well, I
don't think it was but it is basically it was, you know, the talk
on solving linear equations and
There you go. Oh, this is the one okay.
So does that does that bar? Imply? What does
that imply in the in this case? Does it imply a matrix?
Oh, yeah, you mean this vertical bar? Yeah. Yeah, they're
vertical bar means that these numbers these terms are
the right side of the equation.
That's all that's okay. That's all. I mean this Matrix represents
the equations Yeah. So basically
the idea is because why do you have the vertical bar?
Because your attention must be here you want to make these?
You want to make the numbers on the diagonal one?
Everything else that is not a diagonal zero.
Okay. Yeah, okay.
So it's it's not an implied matrix multiplication of
some sort.
And it's no no, it's not some predecessor to
direct notation.
Say that again. Did you say direct direct notation none of this context? No.
Yeah. Okay. So that's it just means they're just
it's just a separation. Yeah. Okay. All
right. That's it.
Uh to ask the one that solved the
matrix by decomposition the one that solved the
matrix by decomposition.
I don't.
Just solve The Matrix which one was that? Well, in
in this example, you're showing is this where you you
basically go through steps to to convert the
left side Matrix to the identity Matrix
No. No, this one is Big. This one is just going
back and forth. So let's
see. For example, if you want to make if you
want to get rid of this too, you have to either take
this equation or that equation.
Add it.
to this equation
or subtracted from this equation or multiply one
term.
With all of these terms in this equation. Let me see if I can be a picture
because I'm just using a lot of words here.
Gaussian elimination basically, that's that's the techniques we're
going to use. Hopefully the picture will
make it easier.
calcium elimination
No, I don't like to know quotations too messy.
Maybe if you can find a gift if you're
lucky.
Sure.
If I just find one picture, we'd be
would be good. Maybe this one.
Yeah, maybe this one will do. Let's have a
look at that one.
so this one says what interchange the first row and
the third row above
So obviously these would be terms and an equation right? So we have three equations.
And interchange the first show in the third one.
multiply the first row by 1/5
And so by doing this so for example, if we
multiply the first row.
That one up here by 1/5 what we've done is
you've successfully made this one.
Now what we need to do is continue this way
for the other term so here.
They've done it for the one down here.
You kind of get the idea what the ideas
the ideas. Let me see if I can find another picture.
You have a look at that. Let me see if I can find another picture.
But again, you're you're doing Matrix operations to
Convert the left side into the identity. Then
once you have the identity, you have the roots in that right
column. Yeah, but I will yeah. Yes and you
can you can swap rows you can swap columns. You can multiply
rows multiply columns. Yeah, I would say more operations
not Matrix operations because we're not we're not involving aside.
Yeah, I didn't mean
to say yeah, it's just more like vector operations on
a matrix. Yeah. This is it. This is when you when you're
Matrix looks like this. I hope this picture like really gets the idea
across when the Matrix looks like this.
So the Stars don't matter. Those are those are
what the roots will be equal to but what the Matrix looked
like when you have one across the principal diagonal zero elsewhere, you
have saw the equations, then you can go back plug in
the numbers plug in for this terms and you would
have known what your models are.
You would have solved each equation.
Now this happens to be that my least favorite part of lean algebra
because the kinds it's arithmetic.
So I stick to
one example, but for the examples I just find a calculator to do it.
Okay. Thanks.
The cost someone else what is the cost of the course the cost of the course?
And let me also let me also say this about the cost if you
open the by the way you just what
you do is you would click on the link.
And you would find the prices here.
So you're able to preview the course?
for one week
if you like it you can upgrade to.
certificate
so right now the price is 600 but there is scholarship offer.
So if if any of you, you know want assistance
with the payment just send
an email to support at big number one can give you discount.
Okay.
You can of course order the course so you
don't apply for the certificate.
but
you know because of the number of people it's hard to
give everybody support.
If you want full support and you want the certificate you can go
ahead and upgrade.
Okay.
Any other questions?
All right. Let me ask this. Let me do a survey.
About the topics that we covered
here today.
On a scale of 1 to 5 how much of this were you familiar
with? So we're five, you know, you've already seen all
of these. This is nothing new to you and one.
This is completely new to you.
So if I appreciate if you let me know.
If everything is known to you if you've seen this before type in
five, otherwise type in one.
or someone number between
Stephanie says three so somewhere in between handcatch. Okay,
so this is not new to at all.
3.54
Okay.
And one more question how familiar are
you with numpy?
Again on a scale of five five, you know numpy.
in and out and one
you really don't.
Okay. Now the numbers are changing.
Okay closer to closer to
one for now pie except for Allen.
No.
When it comes to numpy the
central I have a slide here. Let me actually from a different
size. So let me pull it up.
Let's talk about numpy.
very briefly
because I brought it up a couple of times.
the central object in the
numpy
library is the nde rate.
The n-dimensional array, I mean that's what a matrix is
after. All right. It's a multi-dimensional array.
Array is a sequence of values. For example, we can imagine a row
in Excel sheet and
a multidimensional array where that
could be
Rosen Columns of data
so you can represent vectors.
matrices and tensors with numb but the numpy
library
now the ND array is an object and it has four.
attributes
Okay.
The first attribute is the data that in
contains.
Then we have the D type which tells you the data type of the
values.
the shape
if you have a matrix.
Then we talked about n by m.
Matrix if I said tensor then we'll be n by
m times P for example
And then there are and then the third attribute this is the
strides which is about the number the amount of space this
n-dimensional array encompasses.
So if you're dealing with sports matrices and
a sports sports, make sure there's one is a matrix where
we have a lot of zeros. This is something you'd be concerned with.
Okay.
And this sparse makes it something you will
encounter when you're doing.
NLP if you remember in the last step in the last session we talked about
wood embeddings.
This is related to that.
So what we're going to do is we're going to approach numpy from
the fundamentals. We want to understand thoroughly what this what the objects
are.
And then we will do some basic example, so we will look
at examples where we reshape an array. So a reshape is this so
if you want to produce an end dimensional array, you take
your python list, which is a playlist.
That will be the argument for the array method.
And then if you if you type in shape, well, you will know
the number of rows and columns you have in The Matrix.
You can use a reshape method.
Now this is the reshape method will take these parameters if we'll
take these arguments if you talk about two-dimensional array.
But we can use reshape to well go from
a vector to a matrix.
And of course you can continue doing this if you have a tensor.
So we will look at examples of this and one great
way to learn numpy is to see to see applications different
in statistics.
so how can we use numpy to get a
correlation Matrix or how to how to go
from a covariance matrix to a correlation Matrix how to find
the mean value mean average of the values how to find
a maximum the minimum
and the way we will go about learning up Pi is we'll grab an Excel
sheet.
or a CSV file
then Parts it as a
numpy
Array, and then we will look at the different attributes and
methods of the numpy array.
And then once you've kind of learned the fundamentals of
numpy, we can then switch to linear algebra and the
approach will be the same we've seen here what I will give you some mathematical expressions.
Then there will be one example where I go from the mathematic expression
to the python implementation and then you
will have to go vice versa. You will have to go the other way around.
Okay.
Pankaj wouldn't be possible. Turn the class after the
first week for free.
Like I guess we could make an exception in
your case, right? So again, I want you
to evaluate evaluate the course.
So sure why not?
By the way, after these courses are over the they will
be self-paced. But again, they won't be any interactions if you have any questions.
It's it's not going to be easy to come to to answer because
we would have moved onto a different course.
Okay.
So yes.
Next session which starts?
This Wednesday, we're going to go deeper into the
mathematics. So we're going to
Look at an example of system of equations that let me just say this. We
haven't done this in today's session and the subsequence session we're going
to do in class exercises.
So
you want to be in front of your laptop?
if you really want to make the best of
the session that starts on Wednesday and the ones that come after
you want to do you want to work on the exercise?
All right.
Any comments or questions before wrap up anything? Oh one more
thing before. I forget in the previous course. What
I did is I I put a survey asking for suggestions.
So there was some things that would not cover
in the course and I asked you know, what would you want
us to have covered extra?
I want you to think about that go through
the material.
And see what would have been a nice session
for you to excuse me what we a
nice concept for you to learn and then I can add that because this
is based on.
two things
books on linear algebra
books on machine learning
And then numpy array.
So I designed this course so that it makes you
or it helps you become competent in all three, but if
there's something extra something that interests you that is not
covered.
Bring it up. You can even post it either slack Channel.
and I will
If it's something that is manageable, I will add it as part of
the curriculum.
And a junior. Yes, this session is free. And so well the sessions
on
Wednesday and Friday, so the one week is is
for free.
Okay.
And I will have updates for ML episode
2 and wallpapers episode 2 the video is done. It will
post it.
In a few hours, if you're missing you can watch that.
and
yeah, I'll put a post on the slack channel
for envelope episode 2. Can we get access to the channel? Which
channel are you referring to chirag?
the slack Channel
let me actually give you the link here.
Make it simple. So I'm gonna go pick number.
Invite people here is the link to Slack.
There we go.
Okay, everybody.
Thank you for attending again. I highly encourage you to join
the channel.
If you have any questions.
I really suggest you put your
questions by the way news.
We're going to be joined by.
Other instructors in the coming months who are
from Academia.
so
join the slack channel so that you know you could
you get to ask questions for not just for me but other
other experts
it's
Interesting things are coming coming up. But anyway, that's it
for today's session. Thank everybody. Enjoy the rest of your day, and I'll see you very
soon for now. Take care. Bye.